Angel über die Schulter und los:
Streetfishing heißt das neue Hobby
vieler junger Großstädter. Seinen Ursprung
hat der Sport wahrscheinlich in Paris,
doch mittlerweile ist Streetfishing in
ganz Europa beliebt.
Victor Eras ist gerne in Berlin unterwegs.
Also, wenn ich angeln gehe, dann kann
ich eigentlich super toll abschalten
abschalten so vom Alltag. Man vergisst
so alle Probleme um einen herum.
Zwei bis drei Mal pro Woche wirft der
37-Jährige die Angel aus.
Einer seiner Lieblingsspots: die
Jungfernbrücke in Berlin Mitte.
Viele Leute glauben ja, dass es in der
Stadt überhaupt gar keine Fische gibt.
Aber das ist natürlich ein Irrglaube,
weil es gibt richtig, richtig viele Fische
vor allem Zander, Barsche, Rapfen, sind ja
alles tolle Fische, die man angeln kann.
Das ist ein Barsch.
Den gibts hier relativ häufig –
in … aber noch viel größer hoffentlich,
deswegen darf er ausnahmsweise
heute schwimmen.
Es gibt natürlich auch größere Barsche
oder auch größere andere Fische
wie Zander, die man dann auch
super essen kann.
Denn die Wasserqualität der Berliner
Flüsse ist besser als viele annehmen.
Auch Stars sind begeisterte Angler –
so wie der Brite David Beckham
mit seinen Söhnen,
der deutsche Ex-Fußball
Nationalspieler Miroslav Klose
und der spanische Tennisspieler
Rafael Nadal.
Vor allem die junge Generation macht
die Stadt zu ihrem Angelplatz.
Max Murawski ist 22 Jahre alt.
Das Coole am Streetfishing ist, dass …
ja man kann einfach nach der Arbeit –
so wie heute –  noch mal schnell
ans Wasser fahren und
hat keinen großen Aufwand,
kann sich eine Rute nehmen,
ein paar Köder und dann einfach loslegen.
Mehr Ausrüstung braucht man zum
Streetfishing also nicht.
Hauptsache sie ist ultraleicht, denn wer in
der Stadt angeln möchte, muss mobil sein.
Auch im Internet boomt das Thema.
Viele YouTuber geben
ihre Erfahrungen in Videos weiter.
Hey Leute, guckt euch mal das Wetter an.
Ist das nicht geil?! 30 Grad im Schatten,
eigentlich müsste man baden gehen.
Aber ich will trotzdem angeln gehen.
Mit mehr als 130.000 Abonnenten und
27 Millionen Aufrufen betreibt Victor Eras
einen der erfolgreichsten deutschen
Angel-YouTube-Kanäle.
Seit 2013 kann man ihn dort
bei Ausflügen begleiten.
Also, ich glaube, warum mein Kanal
so erfolgreich ist,
ist deswegen, dass es nicht nur ums
Angeln geht, sondern dass wir immer so
ne kleine Story haben und
immer ein bisschen was passiert.
Und der Unterschied zum Fernsehen
prinzipiell bei YouTube ist eben,
dass es echt ist. Die Leute mögen das,
wenn es echt ist, und deswegen glaube ich,
gucken sie so gern auch diese Videos.
Rund fünf Millionen Hobbyangler gibt
es in Deutschland und jedes Jahr
werden es mehr. Auch bei den
Anglerverbänden ist der Trend spürbar.
Seit einigen Jahren steigen
die Mitgliederzahlen stetig.
Die Ursachen für diesen Trend sind
meiner Meinung sehr vielfältig.
Zum einen
wollen viele junge Menschen auch wieder
so ein bisschen zurück zur Natur,
wieder Naturabenteuer erleben.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es auch so,
dass zum Beispiel in der heutigen Zeit
YouTube-Kanäle übers Angeln vorhanden
sind, bei denen Angeln einfach
ein komplett entstaubtes Image bekommt,
wo Angeln als sehr cool dargestellt wird.
Streetfishing –
ein Angelsport, jung und modern.
Auch das Outfit der Angler ist lässig.
Typische Anglerwesten und Wathosen
sucht man vergeblich. Kurze Hosen,
T-Shirts und Baseballcaps sind angesagt.
Angeln in der Stadt ist auf jeden Fall
wesentlich sozialer, als wenn man irgendwo
irgendwo alleine auf nem See sitzt
oder an nem See sitzt. Es ist cool.
Man kann sich überall was zu Essen,
was zu Trinken holen und
wenn andere Leute einfach so abends
am Wasser sitzen, sitzt man halt
mit Freunden und angelt einfach
dabei noch ein bisschen.
Streetfishing mitten in der Großstadt –
die neue Auszeit vor der Haustür.